What if the father of nations killed
millions of his own
people and got away with it?
A man praised as a hero was actually
responsible for the death of millions.
His greatest triumphs were built on
incompetence and brutality.
They were built on an empire of lies.
The real story of Joseph Stalin is buried
under decades of dangerous,
carefully constructed myths.
These are not historical curiosities.
They are toxic narratives used today to
justify iron-fisted rule.
For years, state-sponsored propaganda and
fear clocked the truth.
But now the archives are open. The
evidence is undeniable.
Today we're exposing the biggest lies
ever told about Joseph Stalin.
We will tear down these myths one by one.
We will reveal a truth
that's scarier than any fiction.
We will start with
the biggest lie of all.
It's the one his entire cult of
personality was built upon.
The myth of Stalin as the Man of Steel.
He was supposedly this brilliant leader
who modernized the Soviet Union.
The strategic genius who
saved his nation from the Nazis.
It's a powerful image
and it's a profound lie.
The official story goes that Stalin's
ruthless industrialization created a
powerhouse ready for Hitler.
That his strategic mind led
the Soviet forces to victory.
The truth, the Soviet Union won the war
despite of Stalin, not because of him.
And that victory came
at a catastrophic cost.
A cost needlessly inflated by his
paranoia and strategic blunders.
Years before the invasion, Stalin
crippled his own military.
Between 1937 and 1938 he
unleashed the Great Purge.
In a paranoid frenzy he ordered the
imprisonment or execution of his most
experienced officers.
One academic study from the periods notes
that almost 35,000
commanders were purged from the ranks.
This included three of his highest ranked
officers who were executed
after a close trial in 1937.
He gutted the Red Army's leadership just
before the greatest war in history.
Then came the invasion.
In 1941 Stalin received a flood of
information about Hitler's
plan to invade the Soviet Union.
Warnings came from his own spies, from
British intelligence
and even German defectors.
He brushed it all off as provocation.
He even allowed German spy planes to fly
deep into Soviet territory.
Ordering his generals not to react to
avoid antagonizing Hitler.
When Operation Barbarossa began on June
22nd of 1942, the Red Army
was completely caught off guard.
Stalin's denial left the border
catastrophically exposed.
In the first day alone the German
Luftwaffe destroyed
over 1,200 Soviet aircraft.
With some estimates put
the number closer to 2,000.
Most of them were still on the ground.
The so-called Man of
Steel was stunned in silence.
According to Nikita's Khrushchev's
memoirs published after his death, Stalin
fell into a deep despair.
He retreated to his
Dacha for several days.
The state was left
leaderless as it faced annihilation.
He reportedly muttered to his inner
circle a quote that was
later made famous by Khrushchev.
"All that Lenin has
created we have lost forever.
These myths run deep and we
are just getting started."
If you think that setting the record
straight is important,
please like this video.
It helps others find it.
The myth of Stalin's
military genius is a lie.
But the fiction of the workers' paradise
is even more twisted.
Propaganda painted an image
of a thriving communist utopia.
This bright facade was designed to hide a
nightmare of terror,
starvation and slavery.
That nightmare began in the countryside.
Stalin's policy of forced
collectivization erased private farms.
Millions of family farms were
consolidated into
massive state-run enterprises.
Peasants were stripped of their land,
their animals and their dignity.
Anyone who resisted was branded a kulak,
an enemy of the state and
either executed or deported.
This brutal policy led to one of
history's worst man-made famines.
From 1932 to 1933, the state seized an
impossible amount of grain from Ukraine.
The entire region starved.
This event, the Holodomor,
was not a natural disaster.
It was an engineered famine,
a deliberate act of terror.
Demographic studies based on now
declassified archives placed a death toll
in Ukraine at around 3.5 million people.
A secret directive signed by Stalin and
Molotov on January 22nd of
1933 sealed Ukraine's borders.
It prevented peasants
from leaving to find food.
All the while his government publicly
denied the famine and
rejected all offers of outside help.
And for those who didn't starve, another
fate awaited, the Gulag.
This was the infamous network of forced
labor camps that
stretched across the Soviet Union.
From 1929 till 1953, archival records
showed that an estimated 18 million
people were sent into this system.
Your crime could be anything.
Telling a joke, being late to work or
simply being affiliated
with an enemy of the state.
The nightmare of the
Gulag was a constant threat.
Conditions were inhuman.
Prisoners faced starvation, disease and
crippling frostbite.
Archival data shows that approximately
1.8 million people
died in these conditions.
This was the real engine of
Stalin's industrialization.
The workers' paradise was in reality a
frozen, sprawling prison.
Stalin's third great lie
was maybe his most audacious.
He did not just murder his rivals and his
people, he murdered truth itself.
He knew that in order to control the
future, he must first own the past.
He started by faking the public record.
The most famous examples of
that are the doctored photos.
In one iconic image, Stalin strolls with
his secret police chief, Nikolai Jezov.
After Stalin had Jezov executed, he
simply vanished from the picture.
Soviet censors meticulously airbrushed
him out of existence.
Rivals and purged officials were not just
killed, they were erased from history.
But Stalin's biggest historical rewrite
was his relationship with Lenin.
Propaganda painted Stalin as Lenin's
chosen heir and most loyal follower.
The truth was the exact opposite.
In his final writings, a series of
documents spanning from 1922 to 1923,
known to the public as Lenin's Testament,
a dying Lenin warns
the party about Stalin.
He called Stalin "too rude".
He described this as a defect that is
intolerable in the Secretary General.
Lenin's final recommendation, written in
a postscript on 4 January
1923, Lenin puts it bluntly.
"The party must think of a way of
removing Stalin from that post."
Stalin and his allies
suppressed the Testament.
They hid it from the public for decades.
In its place, he built a godlike cult of
personality based on lies.
He was the great teacher
or the father of nations.
His face was everywhere, on statues,
posters and in poems.
He was a constant manufactured presence
designed to crush critical thought.
He was not just a dictator, he was an
editor rewriting history
itself to secure his power.
If you think it's important to expose
these historical truths,
subscribe and ring the bell.
You will not want to miss my next video.
Let me know in the comments what's the
biggest historical lie
you've seen people propagate.
The brilliant strategist he was not.
The workers' paradise
that was a slave state.
The fabricated history
that replaced the truth.
These are not just historical footnotes.
They are dangerous legacies.
The image of Stalin as a strong,
impressive leader is still
propagated in some circles today.
It is a myth to excuse
authoritarianism and aggression.
The brutal realities of his regime are
often downplayed or outright denied.
Getting the story right on Stalin is more
than just an academic exercise.
It is a vital lesson in how power,
paranoia and a disregard for the truth
can lead to unimaginable suffering.
The most terrifying thing about these
lies is not that they were told.
It's that they were believed
and still are in some places.
Believing Stalin's myths
once cost millions of lives.
Believing them now
could cost millions more.